let a equals 0 0 and b equal lowercase
b2 be points on the coordinate plane let
abcdef be a convex equilateral hexagon
so convex means that it's not concave a
concave hexagon would look like this so
that's two sides
three four five six this would be a
concave hexagon so it's going to be
popped out and all the sides are going
to be equal so it's an equilateral
hexagon they're not telling us that it's
a regular hexagon so we don't know that
all of the angles are going to be the
same but all the sides will be the same
such that f a b is equal to 120 degrees
then they show us a bunch of sides that
are parallel to each other and then the
y coordinates of its vertices are
distinct elements of the set 0 2 4 6 8
10.
the area of the hexagon can be written
in the form m square roots of n where m
and n are positive integers and n is not
divisible divisible by the square of any
prime that's just a fancy way of saying
that we've simplified this radical as
much as possible find m plus n so
really the first part let's just make
sure we can visualize this hexagon so
let me draw we know one point one vertex
for short zero zero
so let me draw
my x-axis that is my x-axis
right over there and then my y-axis my
y-axis would look like that
y-axis we know that the vertex a sits at
the point 0 0
that is vertex a
now we know that all of the vertices
have y coordinates that are either 0 2 4
6 8 10 and they are distinct members of
the set which mean no two of the
vertices say share the same y coordinate
so they're not going to be on the same
horizontal line so let me draw these
horizontal lines the x-axis is 0 then
you have y is equal to 2 then you have 4
then you have 6
and then you have
8 and then you have 10
up here
now b we already know so first of all
we've already used up the 0 for a a is
already using up the 0.
b uses up the 2. they tell us that the y
coordinate of b is 2 the y coordinate of
b is 2 so we use that as well and let me
see if i can draw b over here
let me see if i can draw a b it sits on
this horizontal someplace and we the the
the the
the hexagon has side length s where we
don't know what that length is but
they're all the same so let's just call
this s this is going to help me think
about it now that i know that this is
equilateral poly equilateral hexagon all
of the sides are going to be the same
length and so we're going to go out here
we're going to go out here to the
coordinate b comma 2. we don't know what
b is but that is our vertex b
now
f is the other vertex that is connected
to a
f cannot sit on this horizontal cannot
sit on y is equal to two it can't sit on
y is equal to six because then this
distance would be super far clearly much
further than this distance over here or
actually you could have that but then
you would you wouldn't be able to draw
really a convex hexagon
so why the next vertex is just going to
have to sit
on this horizontal
so it's going to be s away so it's going
to be s away maybe it will be something
like that
something like that so let me draw it so
that is the next vertex that is vertex f
right because we're going a b c d e f
and then back to a
fair enough now what about vertex c well
vertex c can't be on the four horizontal
so it's going to have to be on the six
horizontal so vertex c is going to have
to be
someplace like that
someplace like that that's vertex c and
once again that length is s this length
is s now what about vertex e
can't be on the six horizontal already
taken up by vertex c so the four and the
six already taken up so it has to be at
the
at the eight horizontal
and so this is length s and we also know
that we're going back to the origin now
so this is vertex e right here we know
that we're going back to the orig and
not to the origin we're going back to
the same x value this is going to be on
the y intercept and the reason why we
know that is this is length s and this
is length s and they both had to both of
these diagonals travel the same
they travel the same vertical distance
this base is four
this base is four so you can kind of
view this as two right triangles both of
them have base four and hypotenuse s and
so they share this side right over here
so they both this one goes out to the
left that distance and then this one's
going to have to come back that distance
now by the same logic over here this guy
is going to have to come back so he's we
can now use the 10 coordinate the 10 y
at the 10
y horizontal or the y coordinate of 10
that's the only one we haven't used yet
for d
and since we came out when we had a
diagonal of length s
traveling 4 up
this time same logic we had a diagonal
of length s it traveled up 4 over here
and it moved out this distance when we
go back in the other direction and
traveling up 4 you're going to go back
in the same direction so this is going
to be directly on top of b so this the
coordinate for d is actually going to be
b
comma 10 the y coordinate here is 10 and
there we have our hexagon
we're done drawing our actual hexagon
and all this parallel line information
they told us a b is parallel to d e
so a b is parallel to d e
and this is kind of obvious here
bc is parallel to e f
b c is parallel to ef bc
is parallel to ef
and then they say cd is parallel to fa
so cd
is parallel to fa and the way that we
drew it looks pretty clear that that is
the case now we need to find the area we
need to find the area of this hexagon
and it seems like a good starting point
would be to figure out what s is and to
figure out what s is it's really going
to be a function of how much we've
inclined this thing so let's let's draw
and you can see that this isn't an
equiangular hexagon that this is kind of
skewed it's kind of we distorted it a
little bit but all the sides are the
same length so let's just call this
theta
let's call that angle right over there
theta and then they tell us that angle
fab is 120 degrees f a b is 120 degrees
that is 120 degrees
so this angle over here on the left
this angle over here on the left is
going to be 180 minus 120
minus theta so 180 minus 120 is 60. so
this angle over here is 60 minus theta
now the reason why i did that is because
we have some information we know that we
traveled up 4 over here and we know that
we traveled up to
over here and maybe we can use that
information to solve for s because s is
the hypotenuse of both of these right
triangles that i just constructed let me
draw them so this right triangle right
over here i could draw it like this
i could draw it like this so i have s
i have
theta and i have 2. that's this right
triangle right over here this right
triangle
looks like this
it looks like this this is this angle is
60 minus theta and this height over here
is 4. so let's see what we can do to
solve for s
this triangle on the left or it was on
the right over here this triangle says
if we take the sine of theta the sine of
theta
is equal to the opposite over the
hypotenuse it's equal to 2 over s
this triangle tells us that the sine and
remember this hypotenuse over here is
also s
the sine of 60 minus theta
the sine of 60 minus theta is equal to 4
over s
and if we want to set these equal to
each other we could multiply this guy by
2 on both sides you could say 2 sine of
theta is equal to 4 over s
sine of 60 minus theta is also equal to
4 over so we can set them equal to each
other so we have 2 sine of theta
2
we have 2 sine
2 sine of theta is equal to sine of 60
minus
theta
and then we could use some of our trig
identities we know the sine of a minus b
is the same thing the sine of a minus b
this is equal to the sine
of a
times the cosine of b
or i should say theta in this case so
sine of 60 minus theta minus this is
just a standard trig identity called the
difference sum and difference identity
minus cosine of 60
minus cosine of 60 times the sine of
theta
times the sine of theta and all this is
equal to 2 sine of theta
2 sine of theta well sine of 60 degrees
this is square root of 3 over 2 square
root of 3 over 2. cosine of 60 degrees
is one-half
is one-half so we could add one-half
sine theta to both sides of this and
what are we going to get so we're going
to add one half sine theta then this
guy's going to go away and then you add
one half sine theta to two sine of theta
which is really four halves sine of
theta so that's going to be
five has sine of theta so i'm just
adding one half sine theta to this
that's five
five halves sine
of theta is equal to square root of
three over two cosine of theta square
root of three over 2
cosine of theta right i added 1 half
sine theta to both sides of this to get
this i can multiply both sides by 2 just
to simplify it so i get 5 sine of theta
5 sine of theta is equal to the square
root of 3 cosine of theta now i want to
use the identity sine squared of theta
plus cosine squared of theta is equal to
1. so let me just square both sides and
that'll also help us with this radical
so we'll get 25
sine squared of theta is equal to square
root of 3 squared is 3. instead of
writing cosine squared of theta let's
just write that's 1 minus sine
squared of theta right cosine squared
theta is 1 minus sine squared theta i
just squared both sides let me just
write what i just did i just squared
both sides and so we get 25
sine
squared theta is equal to 3 minus 3 sine
squared theta we can add 3 sine squared
theta to both sides we get 28
sine squared theta is equal to 3
or
that the sine
squared of theta home stretch is equal
to 3 over 28 or we could even write that
sine of theta
sine of theta is equal to the square
root of 3 over 28 so it's equal to the
square root of 3 over 28. now we can
simplify that 28 is 4 times 7 we could
take it out but that's good enough for
now that'll that may be you know we'll
simplify it later if we have to
sometimes these are easier to deal with
so let's see over here so we have we
have the sine of theta now we can relate
that actually to s
over here we know that
we know that before i messed with this
thing we know that the sine of theta
is equal to 2 over s or that s over 2 is
equal to 1 over sine of theta
or that s is equal to 2 over the sine of
theta well we know what sine of theta is
is square root of 3 over 28. so s is
equal to 2 divided by sine of theta
that's like multiplying by the inverse
of sine of theta so that's 2
times the square root of 28 over 3
28 over 3. so that is we figured out our
s
2 times this thing over here now given
that we know an s let's see how we can
figure out the area
well what immediately pops out
is that we have this triangle over here
that has height or i should say maybe
its base if you view it sideways its
base is eight
its base is eight
and this distance right over here we
should be able to figure out we should
be able to figure out using the
pythagorean theorem because we know that
this distance right over here is 4
we know that distance is 4 we know that
this distance the hypotenuse is s
so we could call this the height of it
right over here we could say that h
squared
h squared plus 4 squared plus 16 is
equal to the hypotenuse squared is equal
to s squared s squared s is this thing
over here so if we want to square s
it becomes
4
times 28
4 times 28 over 3. and we just subtract
16 from both sides so h is equal to
4 times 28 over 3
minus if i want to write 16
over 3 or if i want 16 to something over
3 that's going to be minus 48
minus 48 over 3 and let's see i don't
want to multiply i don't want to have to
multiply 4 times 28.
see we can write 48 as 4 times 12
is 4 times 12 so this numerator is going
to be 4 times 28 minus 12
over remember that's h squared i should
say h squared is going to be 4 times 28
minus 12 over 3 which is equal to 4
times 16 over 3 which is equal to 64
over 3. that's h squared so h is going
to be the square root of that which is 8
over the square root of 3. so h right
over here is 8 over the square root of
3. so if i want to find the area of this
whole thing over it well first let's
find the area of this small thing right
over here that's just going to be h
times 4
so it's going to be
well i could do it either way but let's
just see this is h times 4
times 1 half so it's going to be two
times so the area of this triangle
let me do it in blue right here this
triangle's area is going to be h which
is eight
over the square root of three
times 4
times 4 times 1 half
so this guy right over here is just
going to be 2 times 8 over the square
root of 3 or that's going to be 16 over
the square root of 3. so this guy over
here is 16 over the square root of 3.
so that is 16 over the square root of 3.
now we have a bunch of that we have this
guy and now this guy is going to have
the exact same area right over there and
then you have this guy who's going to
have the exact same area again
same exact logic same exact logic same
base same height they're actually
congruent so you have four of these
triangles you're going to multiply by 4
if you want the area of these all this
area that i've already shaded in so 4
times this we're at 64
over we're at 64 over the square root of
3. now the only area we have left to
figure out is the area of this
parallelogram the area of the
parallelogram in the middle now we know
the base of the parallelogram the base
of this parallelogram
is eight
the base of the parallelogram is eight
we just have to figure out its height
we just have to figure out its height
and once again we can use the
pythagorean theorem so i'll call this i
don't know we already used h well i'll
use h again but this is you have to
remember that this is a different height
over here this base over here is of
length two two i know it's hard to read
now so we can now write
we can now write that h squared
plus
4 plus 2 squared
is equal to
is equal to s squared now we already
figured out what s squared was in the
past it's 4 times 28 over 3
4 times 28 over 3. let's subtract 4 from
both sides you subtract 4 there so minus
12 over 3
and now let's see if 12 is the same
thing as 4 times 3
so this is this is equal to 4 times
28
4 times 28 minus 3 so that's 4 times 25
over 3 which is equal to 100 over 3.
that's h squared so this h is going to
be equal to the square root of this
which is 10 over the square root of 3.
this is 10 over the square root of 3. so
this distance right over here is 10 over
the square root of three
so if we want the area of this
parallelogram it's going to be that
height times the base of the
parallelogram so the parallelogram is
going to be 8 times 10 square roots of 3
or 80
80 square roots of 3.
80. oh no let me be very careful let me
be very careful
this was 10 over
this is 10 over the square root of 3 is
this height so the whole area of this
program is 8 times 10 over the square
root of 3 it's 80
over the square root of 3. so our entire
area now our if we add everything
together if we add everything together
we have 64 square roots of 3 for these
four triangles plus 80 over square root
of three so let's add it together
so we have 80
over square root of 3 for the
parallelogram plus 64 over square roots
of 3 for the triangle parts
and this is equal to
144 over the square root of three we can
rationalize the denominator so times the
square root of three
over the square root of three
and in the denominator now we're going
to get a three 144 over three
is going to be
what that's 48
right 3 times 40 is 120 3 times 8 is 24
so it's going to be 48
square roots
of 3 for the area of our entire our
entire hexagon and so we have it in the
form 48 square roots of 3. so if you
want to find m plus n it's 48 plus 3
which is
51. that was a tiring problem i just my
brain started to fry near the end of it
i had trouble keeping track of things
anyway hopefully you enjoyed that